pourquoi je ris pourquoi je meurs
[Musique]
pourquoi je ris
pourquoi je pleure
[Musique]
voici le vaisseau
d'un terrien en détresse
j'ai jamais les pieds sur terre
trop
pourquoi je vis le biopic inédit sur
grégory lemarchal
[Applaudissements]
la voix qu'on entend c'est bien sûr là
vous l'avez table voit des gars de
marshall et l'acteur qui fait des rues
marshall on va le cd n'est qu'elle lui a
fait un travail extrêmement basses et
arnaud ducret qui fait le papa qui est
fort c'est vraiment qui est formidable
alors jean pascal forcément star ac
jean-pascal star ac' jean pascal à gaza
alors vous alors après la question est
ce que ça vous dérange déjà un biopic
sur et le marché alors j'ai eu la chance
de le rencontrer une fois moi ça me met
juste un peu mal à l'aise parce que
j'adore tf1 jamais prendre acte est
fermé c'est j'ai la sensation qu'on se
sert beaucoup de ça si on dit par
exemple je ne sais pas peut-être que
c'est le cas mais que tf1 on fait ça
pour que tout ce qui va être gagné en
argent va être versée pour la cause pour
la recherche je trouve ça ils l'ont ils
ont beaucoup fait ils ont fait mon
concert il ya de grosses émissions qui
ont fait 4 5 qui ont très bien marché
avec une grosse collecte de dons donc ça
pour une fois ça a été fait moi je me
moi comme je le ressens rien bien sûr
moi je pense que je rejoue leur sens et
je vais te sérieux pour une fois donc si
vous le pouvez filmer ça va être
je ressens un peu trop le côté business
autour malheureusement de la maladie
même quand y avait la star ac
des fois je que c'était un peu trop si
ça peut aider la recherche est bien mais
des fois j'ai moi ça me met mal à l'aise
quoi je parle j'ai pas fini
j'ai pas fini on n'est pas loin du bourg
c'est quelque chose alors c'est quelque
chose que moi perso je vais pas regarder
parce que voilà ça me ça me fait mal au
coeur en peluche quelqu'un d'assez un
peu non je me cache derrière le nez
rouge et c'est souvent la larme à l'oeil
mais c'est quelque chose qui me mettait
mal à l'aise moi perso mais alors j'ai
une première question est ce que c'est
pas bien quand même de toutes parts on
met en avant quand même un handicap des
maladies orphelines et même si elle dans
ce cas précis il n'y a pas de doute je
suis sûr qu'ils vont faire une émission
autour ou après il y aura des bons alors
une collègue donc s'étonner alors vous
ça vous dérange ou pas mais un peu
d'argent un peu jp dans le sens où je
sais pas ça me met un peu un petit peu
mal à l'aise aussi et cette question de
savoir est ce qu'on fait pas est ce qu
on nous utilise parfois moi je pense que
oui donc
pour faire de l'audience pour faire de
l'argent pour faire accepter je suis
d'accord avec vous mais le problème
c'est que si on quand on sait pas on
dégonfle pas et quand on fait on ne sait
pourquoi c'est toujours compliqué il
faut comprendre je suis d'accord mais il
ya des manières de le faire quand même
ok vous donc typiquement si on poursuit
sur ce terrain là ça ne le fait qu'il
devait une chanson tous ensemble ce delà
de la promotion de marshall ça vous
dérange ou pas 100% renverser la balle à
magali on regarde les images de ce clip
et on arrive
j'arrive à vous je sonne à votre porte
voilà vous
recevoir sous un jour différent
ce point
ce qui pousse
c'est un jour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on n'est pas content parce que ça ils se
rassemblent par ce cas le film ils se
rassemblent entre eux en disant ouais on
est tous amis tout pourquoi ils ont
entendu s'ils sont soi-disant copains
depuis la salle depuis 15 ans archi faux
j'ai toujours pas fini pourquoi ils
n'ont pas fait avant pour justement
essayer d'organiser de faire un truc
parce qu'ils peuvent y arriver avec leur
notoriété de la star qu'ils en attendent
eux regardent un genre à je t'aime ton
église parise par le plus c'est juste
côté hypocrite qui me fait chier alors
déjà c'était très compliqué pour eux de
se réunir parce qu'effectivement ils
sont pas tous restés amis on a pas
certain non plus qu'on eu des petits
soucis personnels
voilà dans le dans le petit groupe ne
sont pas forcément là moi je suis
contente qu'ils profitent de ce biopic
pour le faire parce que encore une fois
100% est reversée à l'association
il faut pas croire mais il y en a
beaucoup dans le groupe notamment karim
à mathieu johann gognetti et tout ça ils
ont créé des oeuvres tout selon
l'association au fil des ans et depuis
des années depuis la mort de grégory
donc ça c'est un procès qu'on leur fait
qu'il me plaît pas trop c'est là je
trouve malgré le garba je pense que
justement c'était moi c'est tout c'est
bien tombé parce que la mucoviscidose
est une maladie bon qu'on connaît et qui
est dramatique mais depuis quelques
années après la disparition de marshall
on n'a plus entendu parler ils ont mené
un très beau combat ses parents qu'ils
sont qui est admirable moi j'ai un total
respect pour eux et d'ailleurs je me
mêle pas de cette maman ça doit être dur
de voir un biopic sur son propre fils
moi en tant que maman je pourrais pas le
supporter mais bravo à eux
par contre je trouve qu'il était temps
d'en reparler parce qu'il ya eu un trou
c'est qu'en fait on avait oublié la
maladie la mucoviscidose et aujourd'hui
grâce à ce film on s'en souvient et on
en reparle donc moi ça me dérange pas
d'être utilisé comme inspecte un
téléspectateur ça me dérange pas que pf
en profite ça me dérange pas que eux ils
créent et qui chante du moment qu'on
repart de la mucoviscidose et que ça
serve à cette maladie en fait donc
utiliser mois pendant élisez moi ça me
dérange pas parlez-en fait parler de
cette maladie par vous il a fait des
années qu'on attend d'une escort rs que
parler ça va faire avancer non c'est
l'argent et il rappelle qu'il est comme
le téléthon chaque année quand même bien
sûr il permet de faire de nombreux donc
pour notamment cette maladie oui kevin
vatant oui la chose qui me dérange un
peu c'est que finalement on est tous
attendri par une image qu'on a créé 2
grégory lemarchal
la plupart des gens on va dire à 80 % ne
le connaissez pas ne l'ont jamais vu bon
encore ce soit à jean pascal ou
francesca lo de la star ok le
connaissait mais tous ceux qui en
profitent pour se faire un business
et à chaque fois qu'on y va franchement
qui fait du business autour d'eux écrit
personne qui sort bon c'est lui qui
arrange les titres ça va aller je pense
pour ses parents ou ses 170 personnes se
fait de l'argent en tout cas c'est
l'argent qui ont ces mondes d'argent
mais j'en ai aussi d'image le fait
d'exister on sait que moi j'appuie d'un
corbeau franchement pour une fois qu'il
ya un auteur de deux et un besoin de ça
mais ma mère si tf1 veut jouer le rôle
justement la recherche des bourriques à
fait énorme pour la star ac et tout est
bien tu dis est bien perçu ça serait
bien mais franchement là je pense que
j'ai le droit d'aimer résonnaient jeudi
avec deux films sur les guerres sur la
donc je suis pas d'accord avec vous mais
je voulais terminer vous avez fini